hello and welcome to this video
cling-wrap mathema most are from Turkey
p1 cotton a dog where with difficult
names so trying for my crucified line
again very early III not Catherine
unfortunately but you can of course them
black does not have to play for those
each fiber text every single game can
also play like I do here King Bishop g4
no make some pressure there against them
against the white center
[Music]
okay I wasn't sure if I should maybe
just a naked routine but okay you just
seems you wants me to take it yeah
putting some pressure on these four
words now by this extremely
well-organized so I cannot do all that
much here
try to cover it's not so easy for him to
move the center okay this is a debatable
that's same Wow but that should be okay
for me let's see I don't have a tactic
or anything you know after the trades I
should be completely okay the problem
was my lack of space but now it's okay
with all the trades okay so is that is
that equal or how do you assess this
position I can I don't really see black
being worse here I wonder f5 I mean I
can probably just play a file and make a
draw okay
he's got he's got to pawn rolling but
who dangerous is that I don't I don't
believe it running
I put the knight on f6 and then he has
to worry about his pawns he has to play
this and now now I just stay basically
can try to bring the really check check
hmm what now you cannot move the bishop
so for what are you playing Bishop g2
io9 h5 Bishop e2 94 king moves king e6
and your dukes want or not c5 is very
strange move just Ricans we can run off
it come on
okay so I can believe more more parts
sometimes nights are really funny like
only okay so let's have a look at that
that was a really strange way of playing
this
I mean why this is better in this
position a little bit it's got the
bishop pair it's got more space I mean
it's really nice for white and then you
played this which is completely enter
positional you just have to keep the
center on d4 the pawn on d4 and slowly
try to push me back at its really
uncomfortable in fact this is just
giving me a good position I mean the
bishop is good now and cuneta we still
he trades everything off and then I have
no problem here whatsoever so I think
it's just completely equal now it now he
just has to stay c5 is just very strange
it can only be hacker - black of
anything so King c4 still holds it
talking the six Kings efore now you know
I can try but I can cannot win and that
just that just loses so I cannot super
swung him here because okay I've got a
picture I've got an idea which is a
typically bad piece - super strong so
that is a draw okay
okay we will have a have an H point at
the end cell c5 and then h5 here's just
in time to make the drawn so you can
still draw this ending but yeah I didn't
didn't look look hard enough it seems
here I'm just winning all the pawns yeah
okay guys thanks for watching